Всім привіт рубрика арошестів до дна
знову на Ютубі Підписуйтесь ставте лайк
і разом будемо розбиратися як санкції
союзників допомагають їм наближають нашу
перемогу
останніми днями дуже часто обговорюється
заява німецького канцлера шольца про те
що мовляв треба продовжувати розмовляти
з Путіним мовляв канали мають бути
відкриті і все одно треба буде говорити
і подібне і тому вже бачимо навіть
пісков в своїх хамській манері
відреагував що мовляв їм нічим ні про що
говорити з шольцем
Але в цьому інтерв'ю шольца насправді є
фраза яка значить набагато більше тому
що вона Дозволяє зрозуміти як мислять І
що відчувають представники західних Еліт
шоль сказав що Німеччина більше не
співпрацює з Російською Федерацією
похвалився що його країна змогла швидко
пристосуватися до нової дійсності і
більше не залежить від російського газу
нафти та вугілля
Тобто ми бачимо що великим досягненням
подається те що ще кілька місяців тому
подавалися навпаки як ніколи не
здійсненна
Виходить так що Німеччина і не далі
працюватиме над скороченням
односторонньої залежності економіки як
говорить шольц і що те що раніше
вдавалося лише мрію тепер дедалі стає
буденністю світ призвичається жити без
Росії і ми бачимо що це дедалі більше
подобається самим представникам західних
Еліт от До речі і представник німецького
концерну Rain Metal говорить про те що
концерн планує Значно збільшити
виробництво танкових та артилерійських
боєприпасів
директор концерна Армін папервер пояснив
що концерн може виробляти десь 240 тисяч
танкових боєприпасів на рік а 155 мм
артилерійських снарядів взагалі до
півмільйона на рік і це я так розумію
особливо напружуючись це зробить реальні
метал найбільшим виробником обох видів
боєприпасів До речі і цього може бути
мало Я думаю що захід буде вишукувати
додаткові резерви тим більше не одним
район металом все зводиться та натівське
калібр вже давно
стандартизовані А ми бачимо що за даними
волстріт journal польські військові
заводи вже працюють у три зміни щоб
ремонтувати техніку для збройних сил
України
те що Путін не збирається зупинятися сам
зрозумів Уже навіть Орбан тому єдиний
спосіб завершити війну це зупинити
Путіна допомогти ЗСУ завдати йому
поразки і відправити російську економіку
на дно
санкції мають бути тут дуже важливим
механізмом і
найголовніше що санкції буде дедалі
важче обходити заступник міністра
фінансів США Браян Нельсон під час
поїздки до Туреччини та країни Близького
Сходу буквально найближчими днями
попередить ці країни та кампанії що вони
можуть втратити доступ до американського
ринку якщо вестимуть бізнес із
суб'єктами на яких поширюється
американські обмеження а парадально з
тим крім батога буде застосовано і
пряник наприклад Італія телівія уже
уклали угоду на 8 мільярдів доларів щодо
видобутку газу
В самій Росії продовжується падіння
показників які пов'язані із невірою і
росіян і тих нерезидентів які там поки
що працюють у перспективи російської
економіки на резиденти у 23-му році
продовжують позбавляти
країну своїх грошей і збувати російських
держпаперих продаючи облігації
федеральний позики з великим дисконтом
від 25 чи 40 і аж до 70% від номіналу за
першою ліпшої нагоди уже цього року такі
продажі сягнули понад 250 мільярдів
рублів і темпи лише набираються відтак
поповнити бюджетні запаси Росії
здаватиме дедалі важче А тим часом понад
4,5 мільйони росіян вже працюють
неповний робочий час або перебувають з
простої змінної роботодавця або у
відпустці без збереження заробітної
плати Таким чином тримається доволі
низькі показники безробіття що дозволяє
проводити різні пропагандистські акції
Але реально не забезпечується і
зайнятість населення що звичайно не
додає щастя кожному простому розчисту і
далі як ми розуміємо буде